whether you're a space nerd or a casual
star gazer you have to admit nasa's new
collection of deep space photos is
astonishing check this out they come
from the agency's james webb space
telescope which is designed to look back
almost to the dawn of time and it's
helping answer some big questions about
how our universe was created mark
strosman shares the cosmic slideshow
daunting in scale 7 600 light years away
from earth the webb space telescope's
jaw-dropping image of the karina nebula
details stellar birth in our own galaxy
and dazzle's nasa astrophysicist amber
strong every dot of light we see here is
an individual star
not unlike our sun
and many of these likely also have
planets and it just reminds me that you
know our sun and our planets and
ultimately us were formed out of the
same kind of stuff that we see here this
image shows stellar death in the
southern ring nebula a yawning cloud of
gas and dust reveals a fading star part
of the universe's life cycle
webb's power and promise time travel
this pin prick of light flashed more
than 13 billion years ago and by going
just a few hundred million years farther
back in time with webb we want to see
toddler galaxies and infant galaxies
things that are just forming were you
blown away
absolutely they're fantastic and they
include something that is a deeper
infrared image than has ever been taken
in history
compare here's the hubble's image of the
karina nebula and one more look at the
webs
from a tropical rainforest to the edge
of time itself
james webb begins a voyage back to the
birth of the universe
this engineering marvel launched last
christmas unfolding 1 million miles from
earth 18 gold-plated hexagonal segments
form a giant mirror a sun shield the
size of a tennis court blocks the sun's
heat from blinding webb the result
ageless clarity like the five galaxies
in this image called stefan's quintet
the first image is astounded nasa
administrator bill nelson it's almost a
spiritual experience because you realize
that there was a beginning and we
have come from that beginning deep space
may answer deep questions as amber
strong told us last december they're
more than just arcane science questions
they sort of get to the heart of what it
means to be human it really is something
this cosmic reach back to when stars
first lit up for cbs morning's mark
strossman in atlanta
very cool and to your question gail who
is james webb james webb ran nasa from
61 to 68 he's uh seen as a lion of the
apollo moon program yeah i figured he
had to be somebody very important
he had to be glad you must be tingling i
i think the images are absolutely
astounding and i love what uh
mark and the person he was interviewing
said in his piece which is that this is
if you're interested in where we all
come from yeah this is looking back in
time billions and billions and billions
years ago this is so cool of course also
very beautiful